oh the new Dune trailer dropped a part
two do you want to watch it no I want to
keep myself pure for the IMAX experience
suit yourself plus I need to finish the
book okay I don't want any spoilers
you've been reading that book for the
past two years in that time they made an
entire second movie didn't give it up
okay it's fine you're not a reader it's
okay to just enjoy the movie here we go
you don't understand my dedication to
the golden path you prance around on
your mobile computer God it makes me
wish for another but Larry and Jihad
another look just stop acting better
than us just because you read the book
May the better Jesuit have mercy on the
man who speaks not should too hear the
plucking of the palace okay now you're
just looking at the appendix to find
words that make you sound smart dunk in
Idaho look okay I'm sorry I'm happy I'm
happy you're reading I just think maybe
it doesn't have to be your whole
personality now I I guess you're right
wait it is the bookmark still in chapter
one our Conan Abomination bar the spice
must flow